cars the muse for america's greatest
songs from the complete works of bruce
springsteen to tim mcgraw's ode to the
american truck
if you like it up loud and you're
hillbilly proud
[Music]
that song is untrucking believable
i mean sure it doesn't really make sense
that they're just driving around in an
empty lot but it looks like they're
having fun so who gives a flying truck
but america's auto obsession isn't just
a hobby 86 of american workers get to
work by automobile and the remaining 14
presumably commute by public
transportation walking or in the case of
that one weird guy in your office named
nathaniel penny farthing bicycle
get down from there
stop it
and if you don't have a car holding down
a job can be a tremendous challenge just
watch one woman describe her daily
commute via public transportation i
normally still get the kids out on their
bus on time it's just a matter of not
whether i'll make my bus
this is the first bust
and then i take two trains and another
bus normally it takes me roughly an hour
and a half to two hours on an average
day if i were to drive to work it takes
me maybe 10 or 15 minutes
so her commute would be 10 minutes with
a car but without one she is literally
the length of the movie the imitation
game away from her job which is to say
two wasted hours that feel like forever
but but cars are obviously expensive
which is why many people have to take
out loans to buy them some from places
like this
everyone is approved at buyer's auto
sales regardless of your credit
even if this is my trade-in
i'll approve
even if i'm self-employed i'll approve
even if we have two repossessions of
foreclosure and a bankruptcy everyone is
approved
okay listen i do not mean to be judgey
here but don't approve the clown he's a
clown
genetically speaking he is programmed
for murder
now now that ad is targeting people with
bad credit who are only eligible for
what are called sub-prime loans and
nearly a quarter of all car loans are
now of the high-risk sub-prime variety
in fact so many are being issued they
recently reached a 10-year high and if
the phrase a boom in subprime loans is
making your eye twitch with flashbacks
to the mortgage crisis just wait we will
get there but first let me take you on a
tour of the subprime auto loan industry
and we'll start with so-called buy here
pay here dealers who do their own
lending they've been around for years
and their ads make it all look very
simple
how can we get you financed when others
can't two reasons first we are the bank
we don't have to send you or your deal
anywhere the second reason we can get
you financed is because we don't even
look at your credit score of course in
fact we don't even know what a credit
score is what is a good one pg-13 640 on
the verbal 710 on math 3 under par is
that a good credit score we've got no
idea and that's why you should trust us
and look
theoretically theoretically it is a good
thing that car dealers lend money to
people who can't get financing elsewhere
but in practice these dealerships can
trap people with few options into paying
vastly more than a car is worth it's
just one of the many ways in which when
you are poor everything can be more
expensive the average interest rate they
buy here pay here a lot is 19
with some paying up to 29
and that that interest is on top of
mock-ups and add-ons that can inflate
the price of the car so just look at
arlene jones she went into a chicago
dealership trusting that they would help
her
when she first got to the quick auto lot
she told the salesman she had an upper
limit on price i told myself i can't
afford no car over two three thousand
dollars she says he was very reassuring
like don't worry about it he said you
can handle it in the end arlene borrowed
eight thousand six hundred dollars at
24.9 percent interest over three years
how much money if she had paid off the
loan she would have spent more than
thirteen thousand dollars
on a car that was only worth about three
thousand
holy that is outrageous the only
way it's acceptable to sell someone a
three thousand dollar car for thirteen
thousand dollars is if you slip a mint
condition x-men issue one into the glove
compartment at that point you're being
generous but it it's no wonder that by
here pay here loans had an average
default rate last year of nearly one in
three with most customers who default
doing so just seven months after taking
out the loan and just think about that
seven months is not a lot of time if you
put a seven month old baby in front of
the screen right now it would not
understand anything i'm saying it
wouldn't even know if i was making fun
of it i'll show you go ahead get a baby
right now and put it in front of the
screen here we go
hey dummy hey
you don't know that i'm mocking you do
you stupid little face do you no you
don't no you don't
who knows about that not you you don't
mind you don't mind at all see seven
months is not long enough to do anything
now put the kid to bed you're a terrible
parent
but the problem is the problem is even
if you're just a few days late on a
payment the dealership can repossess
your car and when they do sometimes it
is with little regard for what's inside
when the mother went to pick up her
three children at a daycare she left her
nine month old in the car but when she
came out there was no baby and no car i
wish when you repo a car you check the
car before you take it that's really
just don't you know take somebody baby
yes
exactly don't take a baby is a good
general rule for everyone
whether you are repossessing a car
choosing a prom date or making a
selection in the nfl draft don't take a
baby you don't take a baby i don't care
what they did in the combine
and and increasingly it is not difficult
for buy here pay here dealerships to
repossess your car because many now
install a special device which goes off
when your payment is due
every five seconds the device is
actually beeping at them
as their way all the way taking the kids
to school all the way to work it's
informing them that they need to make
their payment contact their lender
however if they don't then the device at
midnight most lenders choose midnight as
their time of shut off device will not
to allow that card to start
okay
setting aside the horror of the fact
that they can shut your car off that
beeping sound is unbelievably annoying
anyone with a smoke detector knows it
only takes about 30 minutes of incessant
beeping before you've completely lost
your mind
i pushed the button i unscrewed the top
and i smashed the whole thing with the
bread maker and it's still making that
sound so the only reasonable option is
now to set my house on fire
and once they have repossessed your car
these dealers don't have to refund your
down payment and they might decide you
still owe the money because the car is
now worth less than they sold it to you
for so you can easily end up with no car
and thousands of dollars in debt
meanwhile the dealer can turn around and
sell your car to someone else so the
truth is they can make money either way
and the same car can get sold this way
over and over again and to prove that
let me take you on a magical journey
because a few years ago the la times
tracked the sales of one car from a
kansas city buy here pay here dealer it
was a 2003 key optima much like this one
it had a blue book value of five
thousand three hundred and fifty dollars
but in april of two thousand eight it
was sold for nearly eleven thousand
dollars or double its blue book value
the original buyer complained of
mechanical problems and refused to make
payments so the car was repossessed and
sold again in august before being
repossessed again four months later and
was then resold after just three weeks
before being repossessed again from a
mother of three who without
transportation lost her job at walmart
it was then resold again in may 2009 to
an owner who complained of transmission
trouble so the dealer took it back and
resold it just four weeks later after
which it was you'll never guess
repossessed again from an owner who
later filed for bankruptcy thanks in
part to payments he owes on this piece
of demon car but wait we are not
done it was sold again that december and
was repossessed just five months later
before being resold in may and it was
then surprise surprise repossessed again
even though the owner a mother of four
claims she made every payment and then
according to the la times it was sold
one last time before being repossessed
just one month later that one car
changed hands eight times in three years
each time at a price double or even
triple its blue book value at which
point you almost feel bad for the car
which
presumably needed two sessions of
therapy a week just to be able to start
its crappy engine again
now
now that
that is where the la times left him but
we felt so emotionally involved we
actually tracked that car down
and discovered that since then it has
been sold again repossessed again and
then sold yet again and when we called
the last listed owner she said it had
been stolen and i really hope whoever
did that drove it straight off a
cliff
although i'm guessing even then some
sleazy lobster wound up selling it to a
poor unsuspecting fish
now
now after seeing that
you may be glad to hear that buy here
pay here lending has lost market share
in recent years unfortunately that is
only because it seems everyone is
getting into subprime auto lending now
there is a surprising amount of
competition to give car loans to people
with poor credit so much so people
who've recently declared bankruptcy are
being actively targeted through the mail
just listen to one bankruptcy lawyer
describe what he's seen these are all
car loan solicitations high interest
parliament association sent to my
bankrupt clients people who have already
filed bankruptcy
uh here's one that looks like a check
and it's made out to 21 000
i guess it's going to be a used car you
know with a signature and everything
sent to one of my clients here's one
that looks like some kind of an official
certificate they encourage you to apply
for a car loan even if you suffered
bankruptcy
car repossession foreclosure
or all of the above
that is a slightly weird tone of voice
to use there he sounds almost excited
about a bankruptcy a car repossession
and a foreclosure he's like a doctor
saying wow you have herpes hpv and
gonorrhea most people only get one
we've got the hatchery
and
and this feeding frenzy over subprime
customers now includes big lenders like
santander and gm financial they have
both expanded their subprime auto
financing and there are newer players
like scopus and exeter who specialize in
subprime lending and you might be
wondering why the
is everyone in such a hurry to lend
money to people with bad credit i mean
sure in the mortgage crisis uh they were
doing that so that they could bundle
those high interest loans together and
sell them on wall street but there is
absolutely no way that that is happening
that is happening again that is exactly
what is happening right now
and people have actually been worried
about this for a while now is there a
new bubble that's about to burst in the
auto sector does this concern you at all
though that it could possibly become a
repeat of the home loan
boom do you see similarities between the
housing crisis and what's going on now
with used car loans is there concern now
that there's going to be another
subprime crisis except it's not going to
be mortgages it's going to be car loans
yes there is concern that this could be
the subprime mortgage crisis but with
cars and normally if you add the phrase
but with cars to any historical event it
sounds a lot more fun like the
assassination of abraham lincoln but
with cars
sadly this is the exception to that rule
now before you panic experts say there
are important differences here subprime
auto loans are a much smaller part of
the overall economy than subprime
mortgages were so even if they do go
bust this wouldn't necessarily be the
big short all over again so much as the
direct-to-video version with brad
garrett instead of brad pitt and instead
of ryan gosling an actual gosling name's
ryan
and wall street firms insist that they
have learned their lesson and have set
things up in such a way that tons of
loans can default and investors will
still be fine but
there are trouble signs for instance
standards for some of the loans being
sold as investments can be shockingly
lacks
we've seen deals come to market with uh
very low fico scores and in some cases
no credit scores at all yeah the loans
which is amazing so some people joke you
know you really just need a pulse right
now to get a you know subprime auto loan
so
that's a good job solid set up hard
punch line potentially devastating
effect on the american economy top shelf
comedy there it's the rule of three is
what it is
and behind closed doors some in the
lending industry openly acknowledge
conditions are deteriorating in fact
when we sent hidden cameras to a debt
buyers conference in vegas a few months
ago we stumbled on ken shilson the head
of the national alliance of buy here pay
here dealers he sees trouble brewing
because he thinks in attempting to keep
pace with the big players who've entered
the subprime industry his own dealers
have been forced to issue longer-term
loans with less money down at higher
cost to clients who are therefore at
greater risk of default and these
broader lending trends are clearly
terrible news for borrowers but to hear
him tell it it's a great opportunity for
those who buy bad debts and collect on
them these people have negative equity
all the way through
and they're not going to be able to hold
their life together for seven years
you know the customer
you know how to collab
you got the legal expertise
what's holding you back
wow
that is both inspirational and
profoundly upsetting it's like if the
song i believe i can fly merged with the
rest of r kelly's life
now
listen listen the news the news
don't google that listen the news the
news that used car dealers are predatory
is clearly not new but it seems these
days market pressures are forcing them
to be more aggressive and take more
risks to the point where we may be
getting close to an industry that looks
like this
[Music]
do you need a car you can't afford a car
no problem just come right on down today
to crazy johnny
crazy johnny but don't take it from me
take it from my cousin crazy jimmy
come on out there
[Applause]
crazy johnny oh crazy johnny i i love
the smell of deals in the morning i got
a question for the people at home do you
have bad credits we don't care have you
filed for bankruptcy we don't care is
your credit so bad that giving you a
high interest loan we'll basically trap
you under a mountain which there's no
reasonable hope of escape we don't
[Applause]
we've got a beautiful offer for you
right now man this here is a
pre-pre-pre-pre pre-pre-pre-owned
2003 kia optima
jimmy jimmy you gonna tell the people
what it comes with i will it comes full
of loaded with four tires up to one
engine and a beeping device which emits
a sound that will haunt your dream
does it come with anything else it does
man if you check the back seat this car
has a baby in it
there is an actual baby in this car
right now i have serious personal
reservations about the situation this
town is here don't focus on that look
this car is worth two thousand dollars
but we'll let you have it for zero down
and just 200 a month for the next seven
years that's nearly seventy thousand
dollars
no no don't don't do the actual math on
that try and think of it at home like
this act now and this car will affect
every financial decision you make for
the best part of the next decade and
that is a crazy jolly prophet
[Music]
and the crazy thing is this piece of
car is actually an opportunity for
wall street too but don't listen to me
listen to our accountant crazy welter
come on out here whoa
well it's true if you set aside the
human misery this loan has the potential
to cause as part of an over
collateralized security this can be sold
as as a as a
height
as a high-yield investment damn walter
that has disturbing echoes of the
mortgage grasses crazy the point is it
is so easy for us to get you in this car
why it is almost criminal it truly feels
like it should be a criminal activity
and yet somehow it isn't spammy that's
right thank you so much for joining us
[Applause]